du port de beyrouth il ne reste que des
décombres selon les structures
métalliques et les grues tiennent encore
de vue les déflagrations ont mis à terre
un pays déjà à genoux la moitié de la
ville est détruite
des centaines de milliers d'habitants
sont sans domicile l'état d'urgence est
décrété pour deux semaines
le gouvernement a aussi réclamé
l'assignation à résidence des
responsables du port
au lendemain du choc les survivants
découvre l'ampleur du désastre
fg d'anaky d'un choc du compte cette
libanaise décrit les froids qu'elle a
vécu et ne savait plus comment s'en
sortir
c'est tout le monde s'entraide
j'ai vécu l'horreur de la guerre mais je
n'ai rien vu de tel dit ce commerçant
c'est d'être est un peu nos repères
confiance de ceux qui restaient dans la
propre et dans le port de la ville et
non loin du site du drame
le principal silo de grains a été
détruits laissant le pays avec moins
d'un mois de réserves de céréales dans
les décombres en recherche encore les
victimes
l'aide internationale s'organise la
russie acheminent des médicaments et
envoi du personnel médical
la grèce et le qatar sont de même
trois hôpitaux de beyrouth ne sont plus
opérationnels deux autres ne le sont
qu'à moitié
dans un message posté en arabe surtout
et eux l'hôpital et rilov de tel-aviv en
israël propose d'accueillir des blessés
l'aide de l'om s est en route à l'aide
couvrira mille interventions
traumatologique et jusqu'à 1000
interventions chirurgicales nécessaires
on veut traiter les brûler les blessés
indique le porte-parole de l' oms des
officiers de la sécurité civile
française vont également aider aux
recherches
d'abord une capacité de recherche et de
victimes ensevelies sous des gravats des
décombres voilà donc pour ça on utilise
des moyens techniques on a trois chiens
le président français emmanuel macron se
rendra à beyrouth jeudi sur les lieux du
drame
les officiels se succèdent tous
réclament une enquête
une nonne nous sommes même moule nous
sommes déterminés à mener les
investigations et à établir les
circonstances de ce drame le plus vite
possible dit le président libanais au
delà de la douleur la colère des
libanais se fait entendre dans le centre
ville de beyrouth
la russe se demande pourquoi des
matières dangereuses ont été laissés
proche des populations
les jeunes du 17 octobre se sont réunis
par des martyrs au centre-ville de
beyrouth pour exprimer leur dégoût et
leur haine de la glace au pouvoir et
pour dire mes parts et si vous êtes
incapable de nous protéger si vous êtes
incapable de le faire des réformes
beyrouth a été anéantie par le souffle
de l'explosion
encore un coup dur qui mettra à
l'épreuve la résilience des libanais et
des réfugiés vivent au liban
ici à smic rails at radio canada
montréal